Well, the world is a toilet, and
we're all completely (bleep).
But there are still
occasional bits of good news
to distract us from impending
doom, and here's one of 'em.
Happy 95th birthday,
Betty White!
(cheers and applause)
Oh, man!
She's amazing.
Thankfully, the reason the
talented and enduring Ms. White
was trending on Twitter was
because it's her birthday,
not 'cause she died
or said something racist.
(laughter) -She's great. Here
she is with Katie Couric, and,
uh, what kind of (bleep) cake
is that? She's 95.
-(laughter)
-Give this woman a proper slice
of devil's food cake,
not some crappy berry tart from
-the Whole Foods deli case.
-(laughter)
Betty was born in 1922,
so she was alive
to see the Great Depression
and the birth of television,
as well as the rise
of totalitarianism,
which thankfully,
was just a one-time thing
that definitely doesn't have
any modern parallels, you guys.
-(laughter)
-So, we're all good.
Comedians, how is Betty White
gonna celebrate
the big nine-five? Rory.
-69 a 69-year-old. -HARDWICK:
All right. All right. Very good.
-(laughter)
-Points. I feel like that'll...
that should trend.
That should trend.
-"69 a 69-year-old."
-It will.
-It will. -HARDWICK: Megan.
-Let Channing Tatum come over
-and eat that (bleep). -Yeah.
-HARDWICK: All right, all right.
-Very good, points.
-(laughter)
Jak.
Continue drinking
Puerto Rican kids' blood.
-HARDWICK: Yeah. That's...
-(laughter)
-Hey, I'm that guy.
-And, you know,
she'll live forever that way.
That's how you live forever.